[Applaudissements]
et maintenant on accueille do et Sonia
[Musique]
Rand quand j'entends
chanter
Noël j'aime revoir mes joies
d'enfantfant le sapin
saintillant la neige d'argent Noël mon
beau rêve
blanc
oh quand j'entends
sonner
cux le roule bon vieillard descend
descend je revois tes yeux clairs tes
yeux clairs maman et je songe à d'autres
Noël je songe à d'autres
[Musique]
Noël
oh quand j'entends
chanter
Noël j'aime revoir mes joies
d'enfantsfant
le sapin saintillant
neige d'argent Noël mon beau
rêve
[Musique]
blan quand j'entends
sonner au ciel l'heure où le bon
vieillard
descend
descend je revois
yeux clair yeux clair
maman et je songe à d'autres
[Musique]
Noël je revois tes yeux clairs oui tes
yeux clairs maman et je songe à d'autres
Noël
blan
bravo bravo VZ VZ
VZ